you know I debated using the green
screen to try and do a thermoptic camel
of it so the very first teaser trailers
are out for ghost in the shell starring
Scarlett Johansson and let's set that
whole thing aside I did another video on
it already i'm not going to talk about
it right now but i do want to talk about
these teasers and it is multiple there
are five teachers and teaser the best
word these things are so short they're
seconds long first one i saw i came
across accidentally it was the ad ahead
of a youtube video and i was a true
which honestly my mind is kind of the
perfect effect yeah i'll talk about what
was specifically in the teasers and a
little bit but i just love this strategy
i love this tactic of these just giving
you glimpses of the world glimpses of
the atmosphere glimpses of the vibe of
the thing because i think that's a
really good thing to sell goes in the
shower i think if you try and actually
dig into the story and well first of all
a lot of people are going to call it a
matrix ripoff which is of course I'm
unfair the original material predates
the matrix and heavily inspired the
matrix but you know it trying to explain
the story excellent the experience of
watching ghost in the shell that
original anime especially is so much
about the atmosphere and the look and
the feel of it much more so than the
nuts and bolts of the story about to say
it's bachelor it's a great story but you
the visuals and that whole package is
really what you think of first more than
actual sort of the plot progression of
the thing so I think this is a terrific
way to do this and I would actually I
wouldn't mind seeing more sort of
studios and movies adapt this way of
doing teasers so I like the strategy so
what do I think about what's actually in
the snippets looks okay I'm young guy
this is all going to get very
speculative I'm probably gonna read too
much into it because I mean there's very
little to go on from this all we really
got is a sense of the visual look and it
looks good it looks like ghosts Michelle
and it looks like ghost in the shell
while feeling incredibly evocative of
those very iconic images from the anime
from the manga without directly
referencing anything they are at least
to my eye new images and new
compositions but they feel very much of
that world so that's a good thing and
that's a promising thing and I kind of
expected that from from Rupert sands as
a director because I know a lot of
people didn't like his snow i dunno hun
sman I almost liked it there were a few
things that dragged it down but I
thought visually it was a great movie so
I thought he was a it was a pretty good
fit for this as long as he had a strong
script and obviously that's the thing we
don't know yet as far as its temperature
we saw the very first one just have a
weird sort of kabuki makeup thing
floating along no idea what that was but
intrigued as heck we gotta look at
takishi kitano as AR amake I like the
hair I kind of wish they'd given him the
facial hair too but I mean that's just
me being a ve looks great I just I love
that guy I'd love him and everything we
got a few different images of scarlett
johansson specifically you know we got a
nice distance shot very atmospheric I'm
you know we got her with this other
woman that not too much to go on it's
obviously in interaction seeing we've
got no context for it a ton of the one
that makes me nervous is her sort of
going down the hall with the gun and
there's something about her she seems
nervous and and I don't know if I'm
right it looks like she's shaking
slightly and that reads is wrong to me
for the major that the major is is a
very conflicted character and there's a
lot going on but it's all in her head
when it comes to doing the job she's
literally a machine she is on point she
does not falter so seeing that may be
slightly nervous now no idea of context
I mean what it once you get into the
story the point at which this happens
her being like that might make total
sense and be justified in all good but I
mean I'm gonna judge these things in a
vacuum is that I'm getting them in that
one that's the only one that makes me
kind of nervous do the other ones get me
excited no but they don't they don't
give me anything to really be nervous
about what I'm seeing is like that's a
singstar that's a promising place to
start from let's see what else they can
bring to the table so I'm going to
remain optimistic right now I mean my
big concern is still what it's always
been in this adaptation and that's the
story I was fairly confident once they
got Rupert's hands in and confirmed as
the director that it was going to look
good and it does look good so my concern
it it's the story my students that's
been my concern from over a year ago
when i did my first video talking about
scarlett johansson's initial casting so
i will see how it is but I'm hopeful and
I would like this door despite my
natural inclination to really have a
raging hate on for animated films being
remade in live-action I'm still oddly
hopeful for this one so we'll see if
this this becomes the thing that takes
me out of that mindset of always not
liking this or if this ends up just
being terrible need my nail in the
coffin whatever it's the case we will
see but what about you you check out
these teasers yet would you think about
it whatever was drop something down in
the comments and let's talk about it
don't forget to Like subscribe to check
me out on Twitter out council of geeks
give a listen to the council geeks
podcast available on iTunes and stitcher
and until next time this council is
adjourned